género y sexo son diferentes y uno no
significa el otro que yo tenga pene no
me convierte en hombre ni me hace menos
mujer
jubilee presenta espectro invitamos a 6
transexuales para ver sus opiniones
creencias y valores
[Música]
los niños son capaces de entender su
identidad de género 321 ya
tenía 6 años y tengo un claro y rígido
recuerdo de decirle a un amigo creo que
hubiera sido mejor que naciera niña y
recuerdo a la mitad de mi familia
decirme no se puede y mi amigo nunca
serás mujer y un terapeuta decirme nunca
aparecerás mujer tus manos son grandes
tu voz es grave y aquí estoy femenina
así que me gustaría creer que yo tenía
razón sé que cuando tenía 7 lo sabía
pero en ese momento fue hace unos años y
no había ninguna fuente de información
disponible pero sabía que había algo
diferente en mi los niños lo saben de
jóvenes y no necesariamente debemos
decir cambia todo ahora mismo pero
tenemos que darles espacio para que
crezcan y entiendan lo que es los roles
de género son necesarios
321 ya
[Música]
y
y las construcciones de género me
hicieron daño me decían eres un chico no
uses vestidos no juegues con muñecas eso
me hizo empezar a pensar que no estaba
hecho correctamente que no estaba bien
mi punto de vista sobre los roles de
género está muy basado en mi identidad
porque no soy binario y no hay un rol de
género no cierto ai femenino y masculino
y lo que está en el medio solo no
pertenece siento que no pertenezco estoy
construyendo mi propio rol lo cual es
claro pero si no existiera no tendría
que hacerlo nadie tendría que intentar
encajar técnicamente sí que tendría que
construir su rol y desde ahí se deriva
mi punto de vista sobre esto si quisiera
decir algo más sobre los roles de género
y lo mucho que trabajé durante más de 50
años tratando de demostrar al mundo que
yo era el hombre más masculino y me
gasté una fortuna comprando todos los
juguetes que podía comprar para poder
salir y conducir mejor que nadie y
pilotear un avión mejor que nadie
no funciona no cambia lo que hay dentro
de sí así que todo eso de bueno tienes
que ser este tipo de zona o no estás
completo es erróneo
yo solo bueno por mucho que los géneros
hagan daño al ser tan constructivos esa
construcción fue en gran parte lo que me
ayudó a entender mi identidad como
transexual y los roles que hay no los
creé yo pero existen existen y no quiero
que existan de la forma en que lo hacen
pero es así creo que deberían ampliarse
si a eso es a lo que me refiero
la cirugía de reasignación de género es
necesaria para ser transgénero 321 ya
me moveré aquí listo depende de la
persona depende mucho por cierto para mí
era muy poco importante era algo así
como el paso final pero muchos no lo
necesitan como las transiciones sociales
las personales hay cosas que son más
importantes que la transición médica
pero otras personas lo necesitan como un
paso muy importante para empezar su
transición o terminar el cambio antes de
operarte antes de las hormonas antes de
decírselo a nadie y quizás antes de que
tengas una idea de lo que estás
experimentando ya puede ser tu género mi
género fue femenino desde que de niña
desarrolle un sentido de género todavía
me hacen preguntas como después de la
cirugía te sientes mujer ahora y yo digo
no más que la semana pasada si pongo si
definitivamente podría seguir sin ella y
seguir siendo feliz y segura de mí misma
creo que es como la guinda del pastel y
lo que eventualmente voy a necesitar
para completar todo el círculo ser
físicamente mujer no está entre las
cosas que me hacen sentir como una mujer
que yo tenga pene no me convierte en un
hombre ni me hace menos mujer esto es
interesante para los jóvenes
lo que he visto a lo largo de los años
es que cada vez más es menos importante
para los jóvenes transexuales pero debe
estar disponible
las citas son difíciles para mí
321 ya
las citas son difíciles el único tipo de
personas que atraigo es gente que quiere
fetichizar a los trans ellos dicen eres
caliente y quiero hacer esto y estoy
contigo pero yo digo salgamos en público
vamos a cenar ellos dicen no quiero que
mis amigos sepan que salgo con alguien
como tú sienten que tienen que salir del
closet para sentirse atraídos por
alguien trans pienso igual es confuso
para ellos y dicen entonces soy gay o
algo así es como no porque me atraen los
hombres heterosexuales y ellos se
sienten atraídos por me entiendes largo
claro que te gusten los penes o las
vaginas no te hace gay o hetero que te
guste un hombre una mujer te hace gritar
yo exacto es un poco extraño no ser
parte del binario porque la gente piensa
que soy yo quieres tú qué es esto cómo
encaja a mí es como creo que me gustas
pero no sé qué me gusta qué es esto y yo
digo si te gusta entonces
y necesitamos que la gente tiene que
parar de decir me atraen los hombres o
las mujeres o esto no te atrae un ser
humano te atrae una persona
hay riesgos al ser transgénero
la transición es peligrosa la transición
no es fácil a mí me han golpeado me han
amenazado de muerte he sufrido
agresiones sexuales
alguien me amenazó con eso y soy
privilegiada en esta comunidad por mi
raza él es blanca hice la transición más
joven y el mayor problema es que las
mujeres trans de color son las que están
asesinando en este país las personas
trans de color son las que están en
riesgo y este es el problema que la
gente debe conocer pero vale totalmente
la pena porque solo quiero decir no hay
vida fuera de esto eso es muy real es
real el miedo a la violencia de los
demás si es un riesgo pero no se sabes
también hay otros riesgos hay riesgo al
comer y mcdonald todo es un riesgo hoy
en día pero siento que lo que vale la
pena es mi salud mental ese no es un
riesgo que quiero correr porque es esa
la verdadera muerte
amo mi cuerpo
321 ya
podría seguir en mi caso estoy muy de
acuerdo porque este es el cuerpo que
tengo y una de las cosas más grandes que
hice por mí fue en mis días de
transición me ponía toda la ropa loca
tratando de meterme en algo que no cabía
y entonces un día me mire y me dije
sabes te ves también como x número de
mujeres normales hice algunos cambios sí
pero eso lo cambia el hecho de que me
encanta quién soy y cuál es mi presencia
física es tan difícil porque que te
digan que las mujeres tienen esto y
tienen este aspecto y esto y esto es
como y entonces yo no me veo así así que
debo dejar mi cuerpo entonces porque mi
cuerpo me impide parecer una mujer pero
entonces salgo de esa mentalidad tóxica
y digo esperas mira soy una mujer
quisiera haber dicho que estoy muy de
acuerdo pero no es cierto la verdad es
que amo mi mente amo
pero hay días en los que mis problemas
de autoestima son tan malos que no puedo
salir de la habitación y casi no fui a
mi graduación porque pensaba no soy tan
femenina como para graduarme en la
universidad y dicho todo esto no me
arrepiento es la verdad porque si no
hubiera hecho la transición no tendría
una vida
a veces me gustaría no ser transgénero
321 ya
qué hago no sé qué hacer
espera espera no
he dicho a la gente que esto no es algo
que desearía ni a mi peor enemigo
esto no es agradable pasas por todo tipo
de cambios interesantes a mí me costó mi
cónyuge que quería mucho pero era tan
importante para mí que tenía que hacerlo
estoy feliz de haberlo hecho pero
también es algo que no le desearía a
otra persona para mí estoy en desacuerdo
porque no es el hecho de ser trans lo
que no me gusta lo que no me gusta es la
discriminación a la que me enfrento
sigue ocurriendo lo mismo siendo negro
siendo trans encuentras que la
discriminación te llega de diferentes
formas así que eso es en realidad lo que
yo podría quitar si creo que lo que más
odio como todos dicen es la
discriminación porque si estoy en una
situación determinada o en algún lugar
tengo que preocuparme por mi seguridad
solo por ser quien soy de verdad y nadie
debería preocuparse por si va a poder
lograr algo o si van a poder ser leales
a sí mismos tan cierto esto no va a
desaparecer por completo pero mientras
salía del closet había veces en las que
decía ojalá no fuera así ojalá no fuera
trans todo sería más fácil desearía
haber nacido mujer o estar bien siendo
hombre y me di cuenta de que si hubiera
nacido mujer no formaría parte de esta
comunidad y no habría pasado por lo que
pase y sería una persona diferente y me
encanta quién soy así que no creo que
quisiera cambiar eso me gusta ser trans
y ahora de la gina self y pónganse aquí
de este lado
y me encanta
jubilee vive intensamente